how's it going bros my name is playing
The Witcher 3 but enough chitchat let's
go oh it was just a dream the [ __ ] so I
think that was just a tutorial pretty
much nice duds though he still has the
punk rock style I like it
may 12 72 you alright nightmare about
you don't even know that take forever to
explain if dawn some way off we've got
time
I really now talk about it hey Adam or
ham or I want to know more about it so
started in the guest room and Karen
Warren I was relaxing the tub and next
to me is crawfish crawled up my [ __ ]
it was awesome yennefer funny isn't it
she's never been there seems so real in
my dream though was she nagging you
about something
true to life indeed
we'll find her so we're still looking
for our our bane damn it we're gonna go
back later we will I'm not worried
I know we will that's not what worries
me you've seen her tracks she's at full
gallop all the time breakneck speed
through wild lands devastated
battlefields she's in a hurry to get
somewhere or fleeing something either
way it means trouble of some sort me
surprised if she wasn't in trouble
she's always poked her nose in beehives
courtly intrigues here mages
conspiracies there what you expect don't
know guess I thought once we were
finally reunited things would be calm at
least for a while come with Jennifer
good luck uh then we trained with Surrey
it was fun in the dream I went and found
ciri and then we trained virus theory
those were the days hmm little she-devil
no I've trained kids who were faster
stronger but none had her character
didn't end well did it your dream no the
Wild Hunt appeared attacked Siri I
couldn't move stood there like a stump
[Music]
it was just as over a theory okay time
to go then
[Music]
be darling soon time to go and then we
just [ __ ] wake up wait show me the
letter from unified might've overlooked
some hinted then latter didn't overlook
anything we were meant to meet in
Willoughby that's what she wrote
meanwhile one army or another burned the
village to the ground all we can do is
follow our trail so stop talking for a
minute and give me the letter
how about that he does smell of lilac
induces we're gonna we did not sniff it
they must meet soon will it be near
vizima hmm
nothing else to guide us there what's
this PostScript I still have the unit
what we used it as a bed once that's
private that's private
very private I heard about that I
understand I just I think I do and maybe
not entirely but perhaps that's for the
best
ok I'm looking forward to this unicorn
hat part how's it look how far behind
unifor are we two or three days trails
fresh it looks like at least towards the
main road would be muddled there
wait you're that ghouls oh alright we
get to do some action and some horse ass
I mean duels
hey go go
nailed it no problem
[ __ ] sake what the [ __ ] are you doing
with it they're lazy ass macrophages
father let's go before any more show all
right whatever you say call horse
thank you for about this sorcerer I knew
couldn't stop talking about how useful
they are as creatures
now I want to move oceans from their
blood no because by eating rotting
corpses they prevent epidemics hmm did
you know they eat the living as well
no really upset into is theory collapsed
whole story breath all right well I
guess we'll gallop there then [ __ ]
gorgeous this game war is not exactly
going our way we have a side the
northern realms we're out of its realms
- hey oh whoa jeez guys I'm sorry more
I'm so sorry Oh juice
I did not mean to do that Porter's I
swear it is you know wouldn't believe
that gotta believe something that's what
keeps us going
[ __ ] beautiful as helming Oh
something's happening sometime later
okay
[ __ ] saying it betters not sound good
I can music sorry nice wait the Moors
can talk who said that
not horsey no slap that horse ass no
horsey now I love you well he got it
rekt that's gone
yeah come out
okay that's a sweet [ __ ] haircut
everyone has awesome hair in this game I
gotta say I had the same haircut
oh that was close I was sure I did
rockin my man provided you got lucky
your horse died quickly
but Griffins like to toy with their prey
eat it alive piece by piece
that's nice Hawk Court is out ute you'd
like a reward I suppose well I wouldn't
mind if a few coins could always use a
few crowns thing is I've a meager purse
at the moment milf Guardians
requisitioned my goods
now this well I'll take your hand then
no crawfish do you have any crawfish hey
thanks you ready
[Music]
back to the trail like I said leads to
the main road and ends there muddled you
seek someone why do you care what's it
to you well you see there's an in here
in Y tortured soul one around gets its
share of travelers perhaps you'll learn
something they're not a bad idea
especially since that wound needs
cleaning beasts barely grazed me but
sure use a good ride nice and cool you
know straight from a cellar
let's go can I talk to him still he just
immediately starts hammering on that
wheel well that I happened we are
LeBaron agent greetings greetings
preaching come on talk to me buddies I
said talk to me you cannot come on man I
have two swords that's pretty cool
well you keep hammering that wheel and
see what happens I'm gonna go over to my
horse my trusty horse and spank its ass
yeah yeah okey now I'm controlling the
horse how weird as our boards do a
backflip horse so I Griffin this close
to the village strange
never main road that gets the war
corpses everywhere distension sorry
noise just crazy sometimes men - you
need to watch ourselves in white orchard
come on I want to check out a limit
sorry
dismount what is he doing hey boy hey
cow I love you kow kow don't be scared I
love you now I'm not gonna kill it I
don't want to kill a cow what happened
I'm controlling the cow calm down
everyone the cow is under my command
it's going to be alright
Hey oh my god a duck it's a goose cow
you're with me now follow me cow it's
Poots and cow adventures a pity yes
beautiful all right let's get some booze
what an [ __ ]
I steal people's cows but I would never
do that [ __ ] Oh what take that damn
before this trouble
that if your coat of arms the term aryan
lilies they were right to hang there
this ain't to Marionnaud wall of men its
Delphic old man nilfgaard Nils gone oh
[ __ ]
calm down mate
[Music]
hey guys
I stole a cow riches
I'll not drink that Weaver those freaks
well then don't drink you little [ __ ]
see back here beg your pardon for those
thugs no need
we're used to it it's our hair they're
jealous of our hair oh he's just passed
through now a Griffin's prowling about
mmm-hmm I already had the pleasure one
mean Beast me night way for a hunter to
put it clawed leaner so bad all things
one for in a grave it doesn't know good
to wallow in misfortune how can I be of
service
well the drop of vodka for me and you
something to whet your tongue oh I have
some options looking for a woman hey oh
yeah looking for a woman raven-haired
violet eyes dresses in black and white
riding in from Willoughby and strange as
it sounds
lilac and gooseberries smell that
I've not seen or smelt such a lady
believed odd remember yeah especially
hard to forget this one
plenty travelers about though quote from
all over might be worth your while to
ask after all right well show me what
you got thing show me where you got
behind the counter if you know what I
mean sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
this game has influenced me poorly I
will have some chicken I love chicken
and simple some berries and an apple why
not one Apple
pleasure doing business with you thanks
for everything
especially that one Apple you're welcome
shame they didn't have any crawfish
they'll [ __ ] love crawfish men do
witches would you be of a mind to kill
the Griffon beasts a scourge on our land
only killed livestock at first it's got
a taste for human flesh of late we're
here to set foot here at doors if
someone will pay us won't say no wow
what an [ __ ] I would have done it for
free except that one guy because I
didn't like his hair type that's the
only reason help you bandage that up
please
I've not decrepid yet then I'll ask
about yennefer mm-hmm just remember we'd
rather not draw any attention pretty
sure we've done that already
I stole the cow you know let's let's
talk this guy has a cool hat I'm looking
for someone well seek some peace and
quiet out on my face freak for your
brief sounds might be it talk now ready
woman dressed in black and white seen
her talk oh my god I got the Jedi move
folks say the lady rode through the
village a few days back galloping so
fast she not rather bore into a ditch
which way did she go I don't know lots
of tracks leading off the main road
could have gone anywhere
white people the freaks taken Micah's
mind uh-huh
and I'll take your tongue if you don't
shut up
that's right [ __ ]
alright well I'm glad we started there
now that was fun I'm gonna go out and
factions as travelers buy yellow there
mate looking for a woman like everyone
not like everyone and not just any woman
mine smells of lilac and gooseberries
like enough to snap seize it'll lift
your spirits fine I'll have a drink fine
I'll have a drink can we cut to the
chase you seen her or not
yennefer of vengerberg and how she's so
fast with those snap peas it's a great
service edit ever mentioned her name yet
you described her perfectly once I hear
something I never forget come help me
how do you know her how do you know
yennefer water question master
dandelions balance of course the only
way a humble merchant might hope to rub
up against greatness unless and runs
into a very patient witcher it's a
Geralt of Rivia himself the butcher of
lava Caen where is she you seen yennefer
deepest apologies but I must ask is this
about love none of your bismuth none of
your business
yes as a vagrant I deserve no
explanation what do you know tell me
before you appeared it never occurred to
me that might have been yennefer
who would have thought get to the point
a nilfgaardian scout from the local
garrison sewer we're at their camp she
rode in there dark of night black and
white gooseberries and in one honor and
a terse exchange with the garrison
commander raced off where to I'm not
omniscient asked at the garrison thanks
we men of the road must stick together
that's one day I'll be in trouble and
you'll be nearby to help well you really
didn't do that much their army
all right lilac and gooseberries it is
now I'm gonna go back to my cow please
where's my cow everyone oh god damn it
done drinking well I didn't really drink
anything mm-hmm [ __ ] off don't want your
kind here oh my god I can't believe that
cow three against one you're brave
back off this is not killem I don't want
to do anything to you so just calm down
course no I done nothing horses working
witchcraft get him all right you wanna
die I'll kill you
you upset my horses you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you up
Oh God why am I so bad at this
serenading you I'm gonna slap this
[ __ ] ass okay ask me Guardian about
Jennifer where's my cow I demand to see
Mike okay goose goose I love you look at
that goes pimping out I can cool this
[ __ ] I'm controlling this goose you're
with me now goose quack quack
all right goose let's go on adventure
goose goose follow me come on goose
goose you slow little [ __ ] I'm kinda
pets I love you I'm your biggest fan
I loved X goose why are you so slow how
do I bring goose with me I love him so
much go stop do now
that's disgusting all right [ __ ] it
let's just go sorry if the frame rate is
low it's just my computer [ __ ] sucks
I stuck to this boy
and that's kind of sad but is all these
plant things mean that stuff I can loot
oh yeah it is goose goose where are you
goose is it really following me no it
isn't dammit that makes me sad that
makes me real sad couse I waited goose
well then I must sacrifice you to load
goose man
again what if we tell it can you the
goose let's tell the canyon can i
stinking goose goose wake up
No Oh an egg I'll have that thank you
guys I appreciate it all right
I'm not [ __ ] about I'm sorry hello
had no one cared that I just straight-up
murder their goose I would literally cry
forever if my goose egg I mean make
juice goose just died but I don't know
what I'm talking about either don't
worry about it
probably should just [ __ ] get my
horse
oh there you are of course I didn't see
you there alright let's ride I'll smack
your ass later - don't worry about it
the goose loves it the horse loves it
what the [ __ ] are you doing
wear some pants god dammit I'm well into
this game it's [ __ ] beautiful I love
it
alright a Brad I ran I ran my engine
oh god this there's some battle can I
fight them on my horse I want to fight
them on my oars
that's it rose
what's the [ __ ] is bad where did it go
I'm gonna kill it on my sin oh my ah
[ __ ] hell oh it's pretty strong oh
god oh god I could actually die come on
where is it okay
oh wait
Marley it's over really what are you
kidding me what is this
hold to draw what am I doing here
a Guinea sign intensity increase well
thank you boss so I got a buff I think
you need a name
how about good nada that's your name now
gunner onward gunner your name is not
Roch don't worry about it
it's gunner got gunner the goo hey yah
go now hey yah to you sir I'm sorry I'm
trying to write gunner yeah yeah giddyup
alright we need to go through this
[ __ ] guard oh [ __ ] this place is
[ __ ]
I need to photo God don't attack me I'm
trying thank you
we're going to this castle thing alright
I ran all right Oh God wolf I'm gonna
crash them because poor speeder level so
my horse can get too scared and run off
god damnit gunner what are they doing
sorry come on Oh a new city okay well I
better get right out right Matthew
McConaughey hey that's everyone doing
alright alright I'm trying to grow up
this ladder thing staircase is called
beautiful 100% alright alright alright
military come no locals allowed without
the express consent of the garrison
commander I look like a local to you you
look like trouble dead wrong I make
trouble go away I'm a Witcher a Witcher
captain Peter Sud when levees in the
tower turn right past the gate well so
you see you came in s you black ones
aren't so scary after all can even be
nice if you want to don't get a custom
Nordling to the tower go don't give me
what to do it's any gooses here or cows
damn it alright let's check in here how
much grain will your village give
whatever you say your excellency look at
my hands look see the calluses these are
not the hands of an excellency but of a
farmer
so we speak peasant to peasant haha how
much can you give bushels they'll be
more sir but our lads the Tamarians that
is to promise earlier you will give 30
and that will do let us settle on it and
I wish to see the transport soon
thank you sir thank you kindly wow he's
so nice
summoned only the elderman and the Smith
Willis but they said he is a dwarf you
are too tall to be in what an excellent
observation very perceptive of you
Geralt of Rivia Witcher that girl
this explains why I did not hear your
footsteps what do you seek here yennefer
of vengerberg where was she headed that
is a military secret haven't thrown me
out yet haven't called the guards so go
ahead
what's your price there is Griffin in
the area slate oh come on man and I
shall see what I can do come on man all
right it's a deal it's a deal some
questions before I start know where the
Griffin has its lair it kept to the
vulpine woods at first I sent a patrol
there five young men a hunter found them
two days on they only recognized them
because they wore our plate
since then the Griffin has grown bold
attacks in villages fields on the main
road meaning it's abandoned its lair can
I have to set a track I judge from your
tone this will not be easy what do you
require I need as herbs
I need bait a specific herb buckthorn
scent should lure the Griffon from ten
miles off but
buckthorn and you not know this but I am
not yet fluent in the common tongue
probably mastered the basics though
hands up
kill them no first came idioms don't
play with fire for example go to Tamara
an herbalist she lives near the
crossroads
she will aid you Iran Iran Iran I need
bait a specialist a buck no goat all
right well I can use some information
about need more information about this
Griffin it's sex why it's abandoned its
lair shall I bring you witnesses they
won't say anything I don't already know
I need to go where your men died look
around what's the name of the hunter who
found them MS LOF he has a hot south of
the village very near the wood helpful
fellow a little strange
all right well so long then - Mira and
Miz laughs thanks
as soon the Acton exhume Acton what are
you here what is that what are they
don't speak Swedish to me all right
I know Swedish how [ __ ] dare you
that's everyone doing for the pie here
not a big deal
thank you I like the tensor so cute
alright let's get my horse hi everyone
how's it goin matthew mcconaughey what
are they doing
oh I stole something by accident oh my
god I do that on purpose don't worry
about it I'm the present okay I better
back Matthew McConaughey ever had i
right how you doing there buddy
I'm Matthew McConaughey Matthews my
favorite youtuber
I wish Matthew McConaughey day YouTube
channel that'd be so what what what is
it you have a cow for me shut the [ __ ]
up
alright let's find this herbalist and
kill this Griffon it's [ __ ] [ __ ]
I got to do all this [ __ ]
I love your parents shut up sign I'm not
gonna fall for that stupid signs
all right this Court let's call gunner
gunner hey you want my friend how you
doing dinner
Turner yeah alright let's ride gonna
yeah [ __ ] out Rupert I'm going alright
I'm Matthew McConaughey Jesus Christ
okay
oh the main questions to ask the hunters
I thought for sure I had to go here no
I'm going here
alright let's go with the plan I'm going
here beautiful sky
it's very immersive like it
I like it to note about your breasts
it's cool to just see the world and
experience all the flowers Greek they
call me a freak because my hair is
beautiful the haters are just jealous
see there's herb Zeppelin roach where's
the game telling me to go I'm welcome to
use
okay it's here fun it bad I read Matthew
McConaughey's about you know horse
gunner what are you doing
it's crazy eyed mofo alright let's go in
here
he's got it no problem I'm sorry I must
be out hunting Oh for [ __ ] sake
must be out hunting yeah if you leave
your house that's the only reason
policy
use your witch's sensors okay take it
easy
I didn't see that Alice I can see the
trails giddyup giddyup girl okay I see
that he went there so I have to find the
next trail oh that's awesome
move it this is [ __ ] cool [ __ ] tell
you I found you hello this is awkward
you are staring at my horse's ass hey
hey hey hey
only I can stare at doing our science
like that come on man not cool you miss
love here that no what are you talking
about
no wild dogs yes more dangerous than
wolves
okay well more dangerous than wolf come
on dogs more dangerous than wolves don't
think so
it's the truth no why cuz I don't but I
guess you're about to tell me wolves
hunt to fill their bellies wild dogs
kill for sport just like humans
they've learned much from us why not
cruelty to where do you find Neil Neil
guards bodies I'm hunting bigger game
enough guardians the Gryphon killed
where'd you find him
ah I see you were Witcher that monster
slayer they's talking about in the
village I'll show you sure but I gotta
kill those mutts for they hurt someone
will you help that is if you don't mind
blunt in your silver blades on them I
mean why not sure Griffin's not going
anywhere no dogs like though so step
careful now come on you theories dogs
better problem for a while now I'll use
March you'll stop to rape a woman
strangler and kill her man for a chuckle
even butcher a cow the [ __ ] man
that's [ __ ] up akin passage
got stuck to their spa he's covered in
scabies okay calm down man
[ __ ] hell I don't need your life stay
a dear Beach
oh god dogs [ __ ] dogs Oh God oh yes
there it is
I have my shield [ __ ] what you gonna do
by saying don't look at ya don't look
did it did it better that it do what it
it's [ __ ] awesome so far okay
oh [ __ ] not to go nerds friend dieter
dieter you know him we served at the
Lord's Manor together where the black
armies in camp now he was a stable hand
I was the Lord's hunter that was before
well a long time ago
I miss dieter already sorry
hope you weren't close no not at all
dieter was an [ __ ]
can you show me where you found enough
Guardians finally Griffin know anything
about it Wow number two by their
surviving listings alone ought to make
you care no Griffin can hear me or spy
me
three eggs
yeah I got a P towards here one lay
there by the stump headless the other
hung from a branch guts plate stretching
down to I really don't know why I need
to know this watch out for yourself now
bro I'm fine bro like I have cows and
goo still be fine not the first Griffin
I've dealt with not likely to be the
last either hope you're right
good hunting now yeah you know you could
help me [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] all right we need to add
things were celebrating Gryphon
interrupted let's use my senses my
Witcher senses
I'm not using my wish there we go
[ __ ] cool [ __ ]
what is this what am i doing examines
black saturated with blood that is a lot
of blood what else am I supposed to find
anything more oh god I hear something
[ __ ] Witcher senses are [ __ ] with
me shut up dogs snow down there is
something what if I am yeah well who
would have set a camp in the middle of a
road stupid what about this tree
I am examining but I don't find that
much more blood I guess I don't know
what I'm doing gasps groans I'm sorry
I'm sorry I don't know what I'm doing
I'm legally blind oh my god um oh here
we go
all right um there is a drink rinser
older and deeper heavily armored elf
Guardians probably second fast travel
alone there's science okay I didn't know
that that's cool huh nailed it
100% all right it's goes this way that's
awesome man I wish I had [ __ ] these
powers I'd be so cool bro so you had no
idea that me it does it like ever
genuinely upset you when when you
realize you'll never have superpowers
and you're just a pissant mortal I need
to I know the feeling oh god we have to
jump here this is why I play video games
all the time
hey oh okay that was close Matthew
McConaughey can do anything what remains
of it at least
all right I rat a rat there's a couple
of weeks hold all those gusts man I'm
the Christian prime here no more dead
horses time died awful [ __ ] sake Oh the
Griffin it's dead it's it asleep hello
Griffin
excuse me Griffin hell larva and her
wounds have already hatched
yo that at least a week Heather Griffin
must be a male oh so they kill each
other even what the [ __ ] in a bucket I'm
gonna look at those wounds deep cuts
over the whole body not a drop of blood
on the beak or claws didn't defend
herself crept up on her while she slept
type dick shaft dents Barb's a royal
Griffin if that good or bad
beat tips worn grey hairs in the coat
10-12 years old and sorry Matthew
McConaughey off for life when young male
must be about the same age but I don't
know who the [ __ ] you're talking to you
right now
explains why the male I ran into was so
aggressive hunted the nilfgaardian down
here in the forest first then started
prowling the area Matthew McConaughey is
an expert of Griffin examination Griffin
examine Adin Adin I am the Griffin
master yay all right
ask the herbalist I can't wait to ask
the herbalist alright first I hope you
enjoyed that episode a lot of fun leave
a comment about Griffin's and gunner and
I will see you bros in the next one
leave like you enjoyed and as always see
us impressed
[Music]